RACHAEL O'MEARA: Welcome
and thanks everyone
for coming today.
I'm Rachel O'Meara.
I'm based in San
Francisco, but I
love to bring authors
to Mountain View and San
Francisco, because I think they
have authors and coaches, too,
in Mountain View
and San Francisco.
There's a lot of good stuff
that they have to share.
So I'm happy today to be in
Mountain View with all of you
and on video conference to
introduce Shir Nir who's
here today from New York.
And today Shir, he's a partner
at the Handel Group, which
is a coaching firm that's
based throughout the country.
What we're going
to talk about today
is how to get results
through personal integrity
and meaningful inner dialogue.
So a little bit about Shir
before we get started.
Shir brings more than 20
years of experience working
with executives, teams,
and organizations
to increase performance and
create organizational personal
and financial growth.
Throughout his career,
Shir has focused
on working with
senior executives
to expose and enhance
their innate abilities
to lead effectively.
And a fun fact that I'd
like to share about Shir
is that he also works
with the Burning Man team
and recently got a new option
to work with the entire Burning
Man staff to be better and
more effective leaders.
So he's worked with Larry
Harvey and a few others there.
So if any of you are in
the Burning Man crowd,
he's also connected to that
group, as I am as well.
And so today we're
going to cover the three
levels of personal
integrity that
are designed to be on the
path to design and obtain
measurable results.
And how you can also understand,
based on the mastery of each,
in succession creates
breakthrough performance.
So without further ado
I'll hand it over to Shir
to talk about this for
the rest of the hour.
Thank you.
SHIR NIR: Well, thank you
very much for having me
here on your lunch.
I appreciate your time,
and hopefully, I'm
going to reward
you for that time.
Thank you, Rachael
for inviting me.
It's a real pleasure and it's
real fun to be here today.
I'll tell you a little bit-- you
can obviously detect an accent,
and you can obviously,
I have a weird name,
so you don't have to
think where is he from?
I'm from Israel.
I was born in Israel,
raised on the Kibbutz,
grew up working the fields, went
to the Israeli Special Forces,
and then came to the US.
I've been in the US
for about 30 years now.
I came with almost nothing,
worked my way through school,
and now I am part owner of
the Handel Group with my two
sisters-in-law.
My two sisters-in-law
started with this company
nine years ago.
And today, we have somewhere
about 65 people working for us.
The Handel Group, I'll give
you a little background
about who we are and what
we do so you can have that
before I start talking
about the subject for today.
The Handel Group has been
in business for nine years.
We are very unique
in what we do.
We are basically what we call
a coaching and consulting
company.
And we're unique for two things.
We're unique by the
structure we created,
and we are unique because
of our methodology,
what we work on with people.
So the first thing
is the structure.
We have four main divisions in
the company, and two of them
are not traditional divisions.
So the first one is a media
division and the media division
at our company what we do
is we actually focus on
media outlets to make
a difference to people
in the world.
So we are working on TV shows.
We working on radio shows.
We working on contributing
to magazines and newspapers.
Two of my colleagues were
just on the "Dr. Field Show"
working with a married
couple last week,
and it's going to air
in a couple of weeks.
Oh, maybe it's aired
already, I'm not sure.
But we have several
things in development.
I'm a triathlete, so I'm working
with a producer, a Hollywood
producer, to create
a TV show where
I'm going to coach
returning vets from Vietnam.
And we were going to coach them
both physically and mentally
at the same time.
So we are really
committed to media
and to make a difference
through the media.
The second part of
our media organization
is we're creating a digital
platform for our services.
Obviously, for me to do
one-on-one or even group work,
I can't get to enough people.
Through digital media
and through creating
a digital platform, we can
reach a lot more people.
So we're in the
process of doing it.
The complexity of
our program, it
makes it a lot longer and a lot
more complex to create that.
But that's one of
our goals this year.
The second division which is
very unique to our company
is we have an
education division.
Nine years ago we made
actually a commitment
to make a difference
for students,
and we start teaching at MIT.
We've been teaching
at MIT for nine
years about two to
three courses a year.
And since then we grew.
We went to NYU, Columbia
University, Yale.
We are in 38 universities.
The biggest thing
that we're doing
is we actually got to the
Stanford University Business
School and Medical School.
And we teaching in the
Stanford Business School
for full credit, both
in undergraduate school
and the graduate school.
And the course we call
Leading Your Life,
it's called in
Stanford University.
And we do it every year.
So that's education division.
We also work with us school
systems, the Palm Beach school
system, we've been working
with them for three years.
And we work with some of
the New York school system.
And really, in our
education division,
we are about to
make a difference.
It's all about
making a difference,
because as you know,
education doesn't
pay much money to
do those courses.
On top of those two divisions,
which are unique to what we do,
we have a Life
Coaching division.
In our Life Coaching division we
work with individual one-on-one
in workshops through
Skype all over the world.
And in our Life
Coaching division,
we're really committed
to people's life.
We have about 1,000 people we
work with on a daily basis,
on a weekly basis,
1,000 clients at a time.
And again, we go to every
aspect of your life.
Our goal is to really help
you enhance your life.
Finally, the division
I run on a daily basis
is the corporate division.
In the corporate division,
we do mainly four things.
The first thing we do
is Executive Coaching,
so we can work with any
executive in any level
and enhance their
abilities to succeed.
We mainly get called
for three reasons.
The most popular
reason is a CEO,
a VP, an executive wants to
increase their ability to lead,
and they want to
develop themselves,
get themselves to the next
level, and we can do that.
And we can do it with any
executive at any level,
because what we focus is not
on the traditional things.
The second most popular
reason why we get called
is because an executive did
something bad in the company.
Something that is not allowed.
Something that created
a mess and, as you know,
that happens too often.
So we get called in,
and we get called in
to help them clean it
up, get themselves back
into their position
of leadership,
and to start
succeeding from there.
The third reason
why we get called
is because two executives
don't get along
and that takes down the
entire organization.
And when two executives
don't get along,
they really don't
produce results together.
So we come in, and
we work with them.
We clean up the relationship,
and we put them back together
to work in partnership and
succeed in the business.
So that's kind of the
Executive Coaching part.
What we do with
executives one-to-one,
we can do with teams.
So we can take a
team and develop it.
So we do our high potentials.
We do leadership developments.
We do team development.
We do a lot of different
things like that.
We also, some teams
make messes, so we
come and help them clean it
up, get back in integrity,
get back in accountability and
clean it up and go succeed.
Sometimes two teams
don't get along,
and then that creates a mess.
So as an example, I work
with an organization
where they're selling a
product, but a product
came with service.
The problem was
sales hated service,
and service hated sales.
Guess how were the sales?
Not very good.
So after three years and
no increase in sales,
we started work with them,
and even within six months
we produced 25% increase
in sales across the board,
just by fixing
that relationship.
So that's what we do with teams.
That's the second thing we do.
The third thing we
do is we actually
can work with any team, and
within a short amount of time
increase their ability
to produce results.
So we did it in sales.
We did in product to market.
We did it with quality.
We did it with cost of projects.
So we can come in,
work with the team,
and six months later or a
year later results are up.
And the fourth, the
last thing that we do
is we take all these
together, and we
work with the
organization to call
to build what we
called honest cultures.
Basically, to work
with the executive
to design and implement
a culture of honesty
and communication.
So this is kind of
like what we do.
Now why we are so
successful at this
is what I'm going to
talk to you about today.
Where we come
from, what we deal,
what we work with
people on is different
than traditional things
that people work on.
We do the traditional
stuff, too.
We talk about communication.
We talk about behaviors.
We talk about a lot of things
that most people talk about.
But some of it is untraditional.
So at the Handel
Group what we believe
is that happy people produce
happy result, period.
And if you make an individual
happy, proud, inspired
about every aspect
of their life,
and I mean every
aspect of their lives,
that person shows up
to work differently.
That person start producing
result that are inconsistent,
good inconsistent, with the
result they're producing now.
And all we did is make them
happy, and inspired, and proud.
So in our work-- I've been
doing this for 20 years,
and some of the
executives in my company
have been doing it for
20 years, and the work
that we've been
doing, what we found
is what it takes to
make a person proud,
inspired, and empowered about
their lives are several things.
The first thing is connecting
you to your dreams.
So what we found consistently
with 100% of the people
we work with that we,
as people, most of us,
are not connected to our dreams.
We're connected to something.
We're connected to some dreams.
We're connected to dreams
in one or two areas,
but if I ask you
what's you dream
about specific
areas in your life,
you wouldn't know
what to tell me.
Or what you told me would
be a somewhat made up story
that you created on the fly.
So as people, as
we grow up, we get
disconnected from our dreams.
And what we found is if
we actually do the work
and tell the truth about what
you want, about what will make
you happy, about what
will make you proud,
all the time, you
will start seeing
a picture that's
going to emerge.
And the more connected
you are to this picture,
the more successful you become.
Why?
Because you're going to
start having a direction.
So most of us, although we have
some direction in our life,
don't have a powerful
direction in our life.
So we spend time with people
to work on their dreams.
The more detailed, the
more juicy, the more you're
connected to your dreams, the
more successful you become.
That's number one.
Number two, as
people, as we've seen,
is that as people, we are driven
by one thing and one thing
only.
Results.
So we are driven by results
and we have results,
and we look for results in
every aspect of our lives.
We measure everything by result.
Results drive everything.
So some of you, like think
about three results you
want to produce by
the end of the year,
however big or however
small they are.
Three results you want to
produce by the end of the year.
Anybody, throw one
result you want
to produce by the
end of the year.
AUDIENCE: Purchase an
investment property.
SHIR NIR: Purchase an
OK, good.
Somebody else, one result
you want to produce, however
small or large.
AUDIENCE: Get promoted.
SHIR NIR: Get promoted.
OK, good, somebody else.
One result.
AUDIENCE: Run the
Boston Marathon.
SHIR NIR: OK, good.
AUDIENCE: I'm
going to deter him.
Find a renter for
my rental property.
SHIR NIR: Find a renter
for your rental property.
Good.
Run a marathon, good.
Somebody else, one result
you want to produce,
however big it is.
Get connected to some
of the results you want.
I don't care if it's make
more money, buy a new car,
find a house, find the
man of your dreams,
find the woman of your dreams,
get engaged, get married,
have a kid.
It's always results,
results, results.
Yes?
So in life what drives
us, how we think
about everything
is in result terms.
Make sense?
And usually in life we
have result or we don't.
We either have the result
by the end of the year,
if you want to find an
investment property,
by the end of the year
you're either going to find
the investment
property or you won't.
Yes?
And that's what happens in life.
And the results you have in life
are a result of one thing only.
The actions that you take.
So give me one action that
will produce the result.
AUDIENCE: Speak to a realtor.
SHIR NIR: Speak to a realtor.
OK, good.
One action that produce
running a marathon.
AUDIENCE: Training.
SHIR NIR: Training.
There you've got to get
a training schedule.
OK, good.
One action that
produce a renter?
AUDIENCE: Hounding
my property agent.
SHIR NIR: OK, good.
Hounding your property agent.
One action that
gets you promoted?
AUDIENCE: Taking initiatives.
SHIR NIR: Taking
initiatives, good.
So those actions might get
you what you want, right?
You don't know.
So action that we have we
define in three different ways.
The first do is very
clear, what you do.
Everything you do
produces a result,
whether it's going to
be the result you want
or not, different question,
but everything you do
produces a result.
The second thing is
what you don't do.
If you don't do something,
it also produces a result.
So if you don't
train, and you're
going to show up
for the marathon,
it will have a result.
Might not be the one you want.
But it will have a result.
So what we do produces
a result, and what
we don't do producers a result.
And this is clear to everybody.
That's not even like a question.
Everybody knows that
this is what you do.
Here's the third one.
How do you do what you
do also has a result.
So you can do something
in one way, which
will produce one result, or you
could do exactly the same thing
in a different way, which would
produce a different result.
You can have a conversation
in one way, even
say the same words, and it
will produce one result.
You can have a conversation
in a different way
will produce a different result.
If you're nice, it will
produce one result.
If you're nasty, it would
produce a different result.
How you do what you do
makes a big difference.
So the likelihood that
you do that you actually
will produce a result is given
by not what you do or don't do,
but also how you do what you do.
Make sense?
And if you work on these,
if you work on these,
it might not make a
lot of difference.
It's this that would
make the most difference.
Now this is also a result.
Your action, what you do, what
you don't do, and how you do it
is a result.
Therefore, this is
very hard to change,
because it's a result
of how you think.
So every thought
you have give you
an action, which
gives you a result.
In the Handel
Group, we don't say
that you think, you actually
we call it inner dialogue.
Because you don't
just think, you
talk to yourself all the time.
And even now, when I'm talking,
you're not listening to me,
you listening to what you
say about what I say, period.
And that's the mechanic
of human beings.
We talk, and we have an opinion,
or we have an interpretation,
and we say what we hear.
So you're in a dialogue.
Here's the boss.
It dictates everything you
do, everything you don't do,
and how you do what you do.
And it dictates the results you
can have in your life, period.
There's a guy named Dr. David
Hawkins, he's a little weird,
I don't recommend
you read this book.
He wrote a book called
"Power Versus Force,"
and he says couple interesting
things in that book,
and what that's why
I'm quoting him.
So David Hawkins said that
at best as humanity we
are 60% negative and 40%
positive in a dialogue.
60% at best.
He said we have people like
Gandhi, which are very,
very highly positive, and
people like Osama bin Laden that
are very, very high
negative or low.
But most of us as
people are at best 60%.
So if you have a result
in mind, take a big result
that you have in your mind, OK?
A big one that you want
by the end of the year.
OK?
And think about what you need
to do to produce that result.
So if you want a
investment property
by the end of the
year, if you want
to get promoted by
the end of the year,
if you want to run a marathon
by the end of the year,
what do you need to do the
aggregate the whole thing?
What do you need to do
to make that happen?
To think about that OK.
People in your chairs,
think about your result
and what you need to do also.
OK.
Now think about why this
is happening this year.
Why are you making
it happen here?
Why this is going to have
a have and not a don't?
Think about that.
Why is this result
happening this year?
AUDIENCE: Do you mean
why is it important?
SHIR NIR: No.
Why is it going to happen?
Why?
AUDIENCE: You're assuming it's
definitely going to happen.
SHIR NIR: I'm not assuming.
I'm saying why?
So if she wants to get promoted,
I'll take-- you have one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SHIR NIR: OK, if she
wants to get promoted,
why is it happening this year?
Well, it's happening
because I already
have the project in mind.
I got the team.
I know that if I do this
I'm going to get promoted.
I already said it up is a
plan, everything is set.
I am like, I'm getting
promoted, right?
The why it's happening
is because I got it down.
OK.
So first thing, why
is it happening?
OK, now think, why
isn't it happening?
Why is the result not
happening till this year?
So why are you finding one, and
why are you not finding one?
What are all the reasons
that you find one,
and what all the
reasons that you don't?
What are all the reasons
that you get promoted?
And what are all the
reasons that you don't?
What are all the reasons
you running this marathon?
And all the reason
that you don't?
OK?
AUDIENCE: With all the excuses.
SHIR NIR: All the excuses,
all the reasons, right?
So tell me something.
I don't care about the whys.
I want to hear from you,
even from people that did it
in their heads, what did you see
about those two conversations
that you just had with yourself?
AUDIENCE: The first
one is exciting.
The second one is safe.
SHIR NIR: The first
one is exciting,
and the second one is safe?
AUDIENCE: Safe.
SHIR NIR: OK, good, what else?
AUDIENCE: I feel
the first one is
kind of internally, and
the second one [INAUDIBLE].
SHIR NIR: So the first one is
you take in accountability.
The other one is you--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] because
of other external reasons
[INAUDIBLE].
OK,
SHIR NIR: So then
you're blaming others,
you blame the environment,
you blame-- Good.
Excellent.
Accountability
versus blame, good.
What else?
What else did you see
in that conversation?
AUDIENCE: Controllable
versus noncontrollable.
SHIR NIR:
Controllables, say more.
AUDIENCE: Versus uncontrollable.
SHIR NIR: Say more.
AUDIENCE: Like I was supposed
to run a 10K yesterday,
but I didn't because
I got bronchitis.
That's uncontrollable.
So things like why you didn't
do something you wanted to do.
SHIR NIR: Perfect.
That's similar to what he says.
Perfect.
Right?
What else?
AUDIENCE: Self-doubt
in the second one.
SHIR NIR: Self-doubt?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SHIR NIR: Yes.
OK, good.
You're not doubting here,
and you're doubting here.
Very good.
AUDIENCE: I think,
in general, you
have one or two strong
reasons why you would,
but then you can come
up with a [INAUDIBLE].
SHIR NIR: Thank you.
Much easier to
think of negative.
Much easier.
Right?
You can come with a
major list on why not,
and like this list
about why yes.
Yes?
And this is how we run
our life, and you guys
are successful with actually
80% negative dialogue
and 20% positive dialogue.
And it's not a bad thing.
It's just that we, as people,
are designed to think why not,
not why yes.
We shoot ourself in the foot
and say let's go run a marathon.
Now let's succeed, right?
Our inner dialogue is the boss.
It impacts all our actions.
What we do, what we don't
do, and how we do it.
It impacts all our results,
and mostly, we are negative.
Mostly you come up with reasons
why not, not reasons why yes.
So if you have something,
you immediately say,
oh no, I'm not going
to get that one.
That's too hard.
And why is that is
one, because you're not
connected to your dreams.
But then the second
is because you're
in a dialogue is
mostly negative.
OK, so impacting
one's inner dialogue,
impacting the mechanism,
makes a huge difference.
So when we work with people,
when we work with teams,
when we work with companies, we
investigate the inner dialogue.
We investigate the culture.
We investigate what
runs the machine.
Now, the second thing that
David Hawkins said, not
only this thing is negative
and controls your actions
and your result, this is
how you derive energy.
We, as people, are
an energy entity.
Right?
We generate energy.
Negative inner dialogue
equal negative energy.
Positive inner dialogue
equal positive energy.
You have that experience.
You know that once
you go to people,
you can immediately see.
You can feel the energy.
You walk into a room
sometime and say,
what's going on in this room?
Because the negative
dialogue is going in the room
generates negative
energy and you feel it.
I had one of my
clients and friend
came over with his
family this weekend.
I have an apple
orchard, 30 apple trees
where I live in New York.
And they came to pick
up apples with his kids,
and they were in-- I could sense
that there's something going on
with them as a family.
Right?
So this is something I'm
going to have to talk to him,
but I sensed there was
something going on.
Because you can sense that.
So negative energy,
and negative energy
you know that negative
energy doesn't
attract anything
but negative energy.
So as long as your inner
dialogue is negative, as long
as you're generating
negative energy,
the only thing you can
get is negative results.
Now, obviously, it's in a scale.
It's not that bad.
It's not bad, but
it's not great.
So one way to impact results
is start impacting this.
You impact this, you
impact the entire thing.
Now, impacting this is
hard, and why is it hard?
Because your inner
dialogue is automatic.
You don't say, oh, let
me think negatively now.
You don't say I want
to think this way
about her or about him.
You just think, you
like you breathe.
OK, and why your
negative inner dialogue,
or your inner
dialogue is automatic
is because your
inner dialogue is
a result of three main sources.
Number one.
Traits.
Traits, behavioral
traits, You have traits.
We all have traits.
They are inherent in you.
They're hard wired.
They come from two people,
mom and dad, and unfortunately
guys and girls, you are your
mom and you are your dad.
And you can't escape that.
And your kids, they're
going to be you.
It's in your lineage.
We have traits.
I get annoyed by people
just like my mom get annoyed
with people.
I'm tough just like
my mom is tough.
Right?
So you get your
mom's and your dad's
traits, the good ones
and the bad ones.
Right?
Now, traits are tricky,
because traits come in two,
obviously, sounds.
Negative and positive.
Negative traits lead to negative
inner dialogue, negative action
and negative result.
One of my negative
traits is I get annoyed.
The minute I get annoyed, the
only thing I can think about,
you're annoying me.
Get the hell out of my face.
Right?
The only thing I
can do is be nasty,
and the only result I can
produce is not very good.
So traits produce negative
results if they're negative.
The problem with traits and here
are the problem with traits.
They could be negative
in one context
and positive in another.
And that's tricky.
OK, so one of my negative
traits that I found out about
is I am tough.
OK, grew up in the Kibbutz
in Israel, work in the fields
since I'm 10, went to
Israeli Armed Forces,
was in a special forces
unit, came to the States
with nothing, put myself
through business school,
started company.
Sold the company, joined my two
sisters-in-law, and here I am.
OK, I'm tough.
I could take it.
My favorite thing to do
was Ironman Triathlons.
At age 45 I participated in
the first inaugural Ironman
Triathlon after not being
a competitive athlete
in my entire life.
OK?
So I'm tough, and it's
good when I do triathlons
because I can run forever.
But it's not good
when I'm a dad.
So seven years ago when my
son was 10, I did a study.
And my study was I asked my wife
and my daughter, my daughter
was-- my son was 10, my daughter
was six and my wife I said,
how much do you feel
that I love you?
Not how much do you know.
How much do you feel
that I love you?
So my daughter was
very generous to me,
she gave me a six out of 10.
My son and my wife
gave me a two.
And that was a slap in the face.
OK.
So that wasn't good, and
the reason why I got a two
was because I was tough.
I was tough.
I was not nice to my son.
He didn't feel like
I cared for him.
I gave him everything he wanted.
He had everything he wants,
but except love and attention.
So I had to change that.
And I did.
I actually created a plan
with him, and in two weeks,
I was an eight.
But I had to maintain
it for a year,
and every time I didn't
maintain that, I didn't
get an eight from him, I
had a consequence to pay.
And this is part of our method.
What we do is we
create a mechanism.
My consequence was,
you'll think it's silly,
I used to ride 180 miles
on a bike every week.
And I love my bike
clean, loved it's clean.
So every time I rode it, I
would clean it for half an hour.
And I couldn't clean
my bike for a week
if I didn't get an
eight from my son.
It killed me.
It happened once, and then
it didn't happen again.
So traits impact your
thinking, impact your action,
impact your results.
So one of the things you
need to start looking at
is you can start looking and
exploring to your traits.
One of the things you
need is a sense of humor
like, this is the ceiling, this
is the floor, and I'm tough.
This is the ceiling, this is
the floor, and I'm annoyed.
So we have traits.
So one of the things we
do is we call them names.
And we then work to
identify how they work.
Because if the trait hits, and
you already have the thought,
took reaction, and you
now in the result of it,
very, very hard to
take it all way back.
Now if you learn
about that trait,
and you can detect it here
when it only shows its head up,
and you cut the
head off, you then
prevented this entire
thing from happening.
So one of the
things we recommend
is get to know yourself.
The more you know
yourself, the more you
would admit to yourself
about your traits,
the more you're going
to evolve consistent
with the results you
want in your life.
And traits are
one of the sources
of all your inner dialogue,
which then impact what you do,
what you don't do,
and how you do it,
which then impacts the
results you have in your life.
The second one is your beliefs.
And I'll do the second
and third together,
because they're similar.
The third is theories.
So you may wonder what's the
difference between beliefs
and theories?
Beliefs are pretty much I
believe you're a good guy.
I believe this room is great.
Theories are more equation like.
If I go down that road, and
I could beat the traffic,
and then I can get
there ahead of it,
and then I will be
it there on time.
Theories are more
equation like, right?
So beliefs and theories
are not hard wired.
You created them.
You created them from learning,
experience, and observation.
Could be your dad said
something, could be you
read something, or you
experience something.
You created and
you have thousands
of beliefs and
thousands of theories.
You have beliefs and
theories about everything,
about people, about food,
about rooms, about companies,
about cultures, about
anything, about curtains.
And those beliefs
and theories come
in two ways, in two sounds,
negative and positive.
And the problem is with
beliefs and theories
is that you are constructed
to prove all of your beliefs
and theories correct, period.
If I ask you everything you
believe, and you could tell me
what you believe, and I
ask you to give evidence
for that belief, you
will find evidence.
A lot of evidence.
If one day you
change your belief,
you will find a lot of
evidence with that belief.
So as people, we are created to
prove our beliefs and theories
correct, which means that if
you have a negative belief,
you will find evidence for that.
You will believe that.
It will impact you in a dialogue
it will impact what you do
and it impact your results.
These three are basically the
source of all your performance.
The source of all your results.
They dictate what
results you can produce,
and they dictate what
results you can't produce
in a combination
or by themselves.
So the trait can go by
itself an impact it,
or it could be a trait with
two beliefs and three theories,
all working together
to create a one result.
Basically this,
inner dialogue, is
the medium by which your traits,
beliefs, and theories show up,
and the way that they
impact your action.
We call this your reality.
Or another way to
say it, your truth.
This is what's true to you.
This is what you believe
is the truth about life.
And it's given by your
traits, beliefs, and theories
coming into the way you think.
In company, by the
way, it's the culture.
Between two people
is a relation.
My reality about him
and his reality about me
gives us our relationship
and makes everything
that's possible or
impossible between us.
How we relate to
things is our reality.
Our reality is made
out of all our traits,
all our beliefs,
all our theories,
which is a compilation of
our history and who we are,
and our experiences
and our traits.
And that is extremely complex.
So our reality is the
source of every result
that you can produce, period.
So if you want to
have different result,
if you want to have more sales,
if you want to make more money,
if you want to move to
another career, if you want to
have a new profession,
whatever you want.
If you want to find
you want to find
the love of your life,
what you need to work on
is not your action.
What you need to work
on is your reality.
Now what would you work on?
It's a good question.
First, we say design your
dreams, design your life.
So we believe that your life
exists in 18 different areas,
and if you actually
tell the truth
about each one of those
areas, a picture emerges.
And when you design
your dream and tell
the truth about
your dream, you take
that design and you put it here.
And you ask yourself
what reality
would enable this design
to show up as a result.
If I dream of this, what's
the reality that I need
to create that would enable me
to take the actions that will
produce the result
I want in my life.
And if you do this,
you will start
seeing results showing up.
We call this model.
The integrity/accountability
model.
Why do we call it the
integrity/accountability model?
So what we believe is
that if you actually
take the case that you can
design and author every result
you want in your life.
You can actually
design and author
every result you
have in your life,
and you know it because you
have the experience of it.
You just don't remember, and
mostly you don't do that.
As people, we don't
author everything.
Or actually, we author
some things we don't want.
So if you take the case that
if you design and author
every result you
want in your life,
and you take a case
that the only thing that
will produce that result,
the only thing that produce
that result is what you
do, what you don't do,
and how you do it.
It's all on you.
Then you could start
seeing your accountability
in the matter for
every result you want.
It's the good news
and the bad news.
The good news is
you're accountable,
the bad news is
you're accountable.
And if you shift, it will shift.
And you will start believing
that your actions, what you do,
what you don't
do, and how you do
it is a function of one
thing and one thing on only.
Your inner dialogue,
and your inner dialogue
is a function of your traits,
beliefs, and theories,
and that your inner dialogue
beliefs, theories and traits
make up your reality,
if you believe that,
and you start aligning
these together,
this is what we what we
call your accountability.
So maybe if you start
considering that maybe,
maybe, maybe, maybe just you.
And maybe if you actually start
telling the truth about what
you want, and you get
connected, and you
hold yourself
accountable, you can
have everything you
want in your life.
And I mean everything
you want your life.
Integrity is because
we believe that there's
a level of integrity
that has to exist
between your design
and your result that
includes your reality.
The integrity that
needs to exist
exists in three
different levels.
First level is what we
call physical integrity.
What's physical integrity?
Physical integrity is
the physical aspect
of what needs to happen for
every result to show up.
So if he wants to
run a marathon,
there's certain
distances that he
needs to run to
finish a marathon.
If he doesn't get
himself trained,
the likely that is going
to finish the marathon
running is going to
be not very good.
Because the physical reality,
the physical integrity
has to exist.
The bottle is a physical
integrity that holds the water.
No bottle, water's going
to spill on the floor.
Physical integrity
is complex and large.
If you build a power
plant, you need
a lot of physical integrity.
Physical integrity has
to do with coordination,
with processes, with
practices, with skills.
Physical integrity
has to do with people,
like keeping your promises.
If you said you're going to
be somewhere, be somewhere.
That's physical integrity.
Any breakdown in
physical integrity,
however big or small, causes
a breakdown in results.
So if you want the
result, you want
to figure out what's the
physical integrity that
will produce this result.
Number one.
Second level of integrity.
The second level of integrity
we call emotional integrity.
What's emotional integrity?
Emotional integrity has
nothing to do with physicality
of the result you
want to produce.
Nothing to do with the
physical integrity.
It has to do with you.
It has to do with your
beliefs and your theories.
It has to do with, even if you
have the physical integrity,
and you don't
trust your partner,
how well are you going
to produce the results?
Not very well.
If you have a fight
with somebody,
and you need to go and do
a presentation together,
how good is the
presentation going to be?
Not very good.
If I look at physical integrity
and emotional integrity
in the context of Ironman
which I used to do
is the physical integrity will
get me to finish the Ironman.
And you need a lot of physical
integrity to finish it.
Emotional integrity will
get me to do many Ironmans,
and then be good at this,
because I am emotionally
connected, I believe in
myself, I love doing it,
and I enjoy it.
Emotionally integrity makes
the results higher, bigger,
and better.
The more emotional
integrity that you have,
the more result you're
going to produce as a person
and as a team.
Team emotional integrity
is extremely important.
The more you get along,
the more you collaborate,
the more you work together,
the more result you're
going to be producing.
Emotional integrity
could sometime
cover breakdowns in
physical integrity.
So sometime, even if there's
no physical integrity,
if you have a high
emotional integrity,
results are going to show up,
because energetically you're
going to call in
certain things and make
certain things possible.
The last level is what we
call spiritual integrity.
Spiritual integrity
is when you are
at the highest
level, or individual,
when we are at the highest
level of our physical
and emotional integrity.
When our physical and emotional
integrity are at high levels,
we get to a point where we can
start to see as human beings,
and you may have that
experience that you
are the source of everything.
That really you create
the results around you.
That when you show up,
and how you show up,
impacts everyone and
impacts everything.
This is very hard for us to
get as people, very hard,
but when you get
that, you then can
show up consistently or
at least consistently
work to get yourself
up to that level.
And this is when you
get there, it's awesome,
because you literally start
seeing how the world falls
and how you show up, and how you
make a difference in the world.
For a team, spiritual
integrity has
to do with the connection
or the alignment of all
the emotional integrity.
So one of the things I've
been doing with my company
is we create something
called the mastermind.
Mastermind came from a guy named
Napoleon Hill who wrote books
in the 20s, and he used to
work with people like Carnegie
and Ford and some of those guys.
And one of the things,
he wrote a book called,
"The Secret of Success in 16
Chapters", and he wrote a book,
and he actually worked
with those guys,
and he created a
mastermind with them.
And what he said
that nobody knows
is those guys used
to meet once a month,
and they created a team of
very successful entrepreneurs
that were committed to
each other's success.
And once a month they
used to get together
and they use to help
each other with their
with their personal
aims and personal goals.
So a mastermind is created or
spiritual integrity in a team
is created when all the
emotional integrity is aligned,
where everybody's moving
in the same direction.
Your personal goals fits
with the team goals,
and the team goals fits
your personal goals.
When that happens,
the team is successful
no matter how bad the market is.
The company's successful no
matter how bad the market is.
You know that there are some
companies that consistently
excel no matter
how the market is,
and that has nothing to
do with anything else
other than the team and
the people in the company
are just working differently.
And they drive the
success of the company.
So what we say is,
if you continuously
work, design your dreams,
understand yourself as a human
being, who you are and how you
think, look at your traits,
look at those traits
that don't work.
The ones that get
you in trouble,
the ones that get
you off the mark.
Look at your
beliefs and theories
and see how my beliefs and
theories are enabling me
or disabling me.
And if they disable
you, get rid of them.
Why do you need them?
They only disable you.
And start aligning your
reality with your dreams,
sooner or later you're going
to get your results to go up.
So that's kind of it.
I'll give you time
to ask questions,
and I would be glad
to answer any of them.
You've got five minutes.
Wow, I thought I had more time.
So any questions?
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit
on the designing your
life bit and connecting
that to impacting
your inner dialogue?
Like, how do you
design-- what are
like quick reasons [INAUDIBLE]?
SHIR NIR: So what are quick
ways to design your life?
A quick way to design your
life is really tell the truth.
It's hard for people to design
life, because most of us
think that we know
what we want, right?
But really tell the
truth and go down deep,
and say to yourself, OK, in this
area what would I really want?
What's my dream?
And put away all the nos, and
I can't, and all that noise.
What if you can get
anything you want?
What would you want to get?
Not a pie in the sky.
I want to be a millionaire
in five minutes.
It's not going to happen.
But you know,
something reasonable.
I want to have a community
of people that love me.
I want to have my own company.
I want to help
people doing this.
There's a lot of different
things in your life
that you really can
see and that you want.
And the only thing
that stands between you
is I don't have enough time,
who am I to want these things.
On this, on that, they I can't,
I won't, and all that stuff.
So your life, there are
certain things in your life
that you made happen, right?
That were not easy
to make happen.
Get connected to them first.
See where you made
something happen
that wasn't going
to happen anyway.
Get connected to your
ability to author something.
And then go and answer the
question, if I wanted anything
in my life, what would I want?
And then look at
different areas.
Look at love, look at
intimacy, look at friendships,
look at career,
look at money, look
at every aspect of your
life, and then start
designing each one
on its own and give
as much details as possible.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
October weekend?
SHIR NIR: We have a, by the
way, a Designing Your Life
weekend in Menlo Park
October 19 and 20
that is given by my
Life Coaching division,
and we have some brochures here,
and you can go online and look
at it as well if this is
something you're interested in.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Some of
the examples you
gave in the beginning of
your coaching practice?
SHIR NIR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
situational.
Like with companies in
a particular situation,
and I'm curious when you
bring such a broad perspective
to a situation, can you
talk about some instances?
I mean, it seems like
you have, in one sense,
you have a commitment
to solve a situation,
but what you're bringing
is a lot broader.
And it seems like
sometimes you might
get results that are completely
inappropriate for what you were
brought in for, like
an executive realizes
this is totally what
they want to do in life.
How you deal with--
can you give examples,
or can you talk about
those kind [INAUDIBLE]?
SHIR NIR: Yeah, so
usually and executive
that come to a conclusion like
this is something they totally
didn't want to do
in their lives,
actually, finally
telling the truth.
So mostly, those executives
are not as successful
as they could be.
So telling the truth is
actually good for both
of them and their bosses.
Because why they're
not producing
is because they're
not connecting.
Why they're not producing
is because they're
not happy and is because
that's not their dreams.
So when you move
a person like this
and get them connected
to their dreams,
and they finally go and do
what they really love to do,
they excel.
And then you could put
somebody else in their position
who can excel, too,
because it's their dreams.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SHIR NIR: So our method is
really about telling the truth.
And we believe that if
you tell the truth, which
a lot of time
executives and company
don't, because they're afraid
of whatever is going to happen.
If you tell the truth, you
can work out everything.
And when you tell
the truth, and you
deal with the truth
with integrity,
your ability to take the
business to the next level
is going to increase.
And we've seen it over,
and over, and over again
in businesses.